[Applaudissements]
c'est gagner longueuillois vous gagnez
ça ya 200 kg nourriture grégoire j'ai
juste appris qu'à vous demandez vous
avez le permis poids lourds ou pas alors
non je crois pas je sais pas c'est banal
j'ai voiture la rose avait permis poids
lourds ou pas c'est important pour moi
parce que a permis poids lourds en fait
le vrai cadeau kakek lascive non mais
parce qu'il faut trouver le père nous
voulons parce que le vrai cadeau pour
les restos du coeur il est pas là il est
pas là parce que on n'a pas 200 kg de
nourriture pour les restos du coeur on
n'a pas de sens qu'il en a des tonnes de
nourriture qui partent tout de suite
bon les restos du coeur on veut boire
dix tonnes de nourriture qui partent
tout de suite
et on aime les restos du coeur et on
ouvre les soutiendra toujours c'est très
très très important grossiste août les
restos du coeur 10 tonnes de nourriture
qui vont partir ce soir gras de la grâce
à une enseigne voilà qui est une fille
qui fait un truc fabuleux voilà qui est
excellent il
c'est vide comprenez voilà merci et sa
part 10 tonnes de nourriture
merci mon devoir c'est grâce à grégoire
aussi sa part pour les restos du coeur
sa part péter shérif local mis au point
ce soir
merci mes chéris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les connaître
tiens et intel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]